而且搶它的結構跟那個沒那麼好 可以看就被打了 因為這裡包鞋子 你鞋子不可能放那麼高啦 對
你頂多在這個高度 以上其實應該是通的 或者是放一些東西 那放一些東西的前提下 我頂多是兩下這裡兩三支管從這附近過 你不需要打這個球 對
但是它的管就是從這邊落電跟那個貼環上去 然後我到時候要全包 然後它的盤底的面板全部拆掉 拍拍手以後打開我看的到他的盤跟管
我直接幫你 直接外移嗎 不是啦 我直接幫你拆掉嗎 沒有沒有沒有 我說面蓋啊
你那個深度跟我面 以後一定是拍拍手去看他的 對 我一定拍拍手去看他的 對
對啊 所以 就這裡兩支直接出來嘛所以可以不打牆從下面看同盤下面這裡要打
你直接管拉出來就好
然後因為我已經不要這個幹部
你現在是說你這裡有一個公司面嗎
我一個人在這裡帶的
對 既然裝載面我可能要全包
那這裡的那個門檔啊
跟這個可能要稍微讓我退掉
到時候可能要抓一個那個你意思是我這個面板拆掉之後我就管制住進來打出了進去是不是聽我講我講你看是不是這個我們都先不動我們都不動你們以後會去拆這一塊可是如果連這一個門板都拆了應該是連這個都拆了啦 連你們家的包啊 你們也包出來 放鬆 或者是在上面拆了
這個我都不 我就把兩個面板那個就直接讓彎出來 直接彎出來 這樣不用那個方式直接洗出去
OK 我就讓彎出來 這段我一定要用軟管 我會把它固定好我會把它固定好嗎?我會把它固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?固定好嗎?我會固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎?固定好嗎它如果做行貴行,你問我說20公分左右你應該拉得過吧?
如果他們可以保證結構不會影響的問題,當然是在場地裡面,所以有點不一樣?可是老實說他們現在不可能說管制之白一定我先看喔等一下